we see there's lots of different kinds
of questions you can ask that therefore
sort of implies when you have a look at
the different kinds of questions there's
lots of different kinds of data you can
get out of those questions and not all
data is created equally well I should
say not all data are created equally
it's actually plural but anyway when you
have a look at these questions and the
kind of daughter you get out of there if
you want to have a think about these
systematically this tree diagram will
really help you the like I said before
the society cultural people will be like
ah yeah okay this is reusing bells but
this will kind of give you a lens to
interpret okay what kinds of questions
about getting out of here
and which diver is useful to me in this
situation so yes I guess the funny thing
about surveys is you can ask questions
in any way you like
so I suppose I suppose this could be I
don't I struggle a little bit and think
about the kind of question you could ask
okay so refocus sorry let me try to
explore these mean okay and again I'm
gonna give you the 50 days bullet but I
will try to illustrate me along the way
what's good
so the first kind of data if I go along
with these kinds of questions that we
didn't get asked if you have a scale
right and you gave it a question that's
kind of like not okay from from this to
this
okay there are two different kinds of
ways you can say that so the first is a
categorical skin okay so the simple way
of thinking about categorical data is
its words okay you could call it
qualitative data if you like but
basically this is verbal in some way it
involves words of some kind right now we
did the category of words there's
different kinds of words and answers for
questions but you have to handle
differently okay so the first one is
what we call novel category okay
knowledge there that's a name so if I
said to you what is your eye color right
you would say if it's white blue green
brown whatever okay that's not middle
categorical data so I'm gonna say I come
to you because you had to answer with a
word clearly but importantly unlike
safer this scale this look autumn right
don't like my blue in stress big green
then brown etc there's no reasonable way
to kind of like put them in a series on
the other hand if you have words that
haven't ordered to that we call them
originally ordinal categorical Donna
right so examples are things like we
were talking about over here like
strongly disagree
you know neutral agree or like if you
get a textbook I will describe the
quality of that textbook you're gonna
give a word like Fair terrible falling
to pieces brand-new those are all still
words right but you can order them in
some way right so for example st. book
quality as my
there's still words though would ever
say oh I give that book of seven okay
you'd use a word to describe it why it's
a holiday right your goodies words but
the words can't be ordered okay
now this is how a be over to hear
obviously what you're thinking about
water mostly it's going to be numerical
done right we have a different word for
that here quantitative as you you can
expect as a quantity but what it really
means is rather than being it's
numerical okay so again we can break
this up into two separate categories you
can think about numbers that can only be
whole numbers so I think before someone
talked about I think was the other I
betcha I have any children how many
siblings do you have
okay so we would say this is a memo
which has to be a whole number
again we haven't we always have we call
this discreet quantitative data not to
be confused with discrete like like
right like that's the secretive as
opposed to describe which actually comes
through the Latin word for separators
right it looks like one two three these
are separate from each other so discreet
I need my example was on number of
siblings there's actually this famous
car ad back from when I was normal it
said the average Australian family has
2.3 children has it this like this up is
some acidity looking kid who's about by
so if you guys feels like the 0.3 of a
child that's like that's an average
actual number similar to the fairway
they're coming I think it's where dad
anyway now the opposite of discrete well
you've got numbers that are charting
this separated out is continuous so if I
asked you for your height it's not like
you have to be exactly five point or
exactly six would there's a whole bunch
of different things in between there's a
range well you may be exactly five for
it but you might be somewhere in between
and there's no like oh you got me this
one of that one so if I say height if
you've got anything
is arranged okay you could have like 150
two point three centimeters or whatever
it is then we call that continuous quest
and